The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
We are going to finish up
acid-base titration stuff today.
And I think actually most of
you have probably ventured into
the Problem Set,
which is great.
I think the best way to learn
acid-base titrations is usually
you hear a little bit about
acid-base titrations,
then sit down and try to do
problems, go back and revisit
how to do the problems and then
try it again.
This is one of the units where
you really cannot learn how to
do it by just sort of listening
to a lecture.
You have to sit down and work
numerous problems.
That may be true in other
units.
But I think it is particularly
true in this one,
that it is all about practicing
doing the problems,
so it is real important to work
through a number of them.
And you will have other
opportunities.
Of course, this will be
material on Exam 3.
But also acid-base titration
always makes an appearance on
the final.
It will be well worth your time
to work these problems.
They will be worth a number of
points for the rest of the
semester.
And, as I said,
you will see all this
information again in organic
chemistry, in biochemistry,
and a lot of other courses that
you take.
You will talk about pKa's and
buffers in biology.
You will see all this again.
All right.
We were talking about the
titration of a weak acid with a
strong base, and we went through
this figure on Monday.
And the particular problem that
we were working,
we are going to go through and
look at different time points
along the titration and
calculate what the pH is.
And the problem we were working
was 25 mLs of a 0.1 molar
solution of a weak acid titrated
with a strong base.
In this case,
NaOH.
And that was 0.15 molar.
And you were given the Ka for
the weak acid in this problem.
We had done one time point,
and that was the initial time
point when no strong base had
been added yet.
Let me just put that down.
We are plotting the volume of
the strong base that is added
versus pH.
And we had one time point,
and that was a pH of 2.38.
And that was when there was
zero mLs of the strong base
added.
So just the pH of the weak acid
in water was 2.38 for pH.
And then we had started
calculating what happens at 5
mLs, when 5 mLs of the strong
base is added,
and that is this time point
here.
Here we are in between zero and
the volume at the equivalence
point, and we have the 5 mLs.
Let me just review.
We talked about this right at
the end of class.
The first step in doing this
type of problem is to figure out
how many moles of both the weak
acid that you have in the
problem and the number of moles
of strong base that have been
added so far.
For the acid,
there was 25 mLs originally of
0.1 molar solution,
so 2.5x10^-3 moles of the weak
acid.
And for the strong base,
now we have added 5 mLs of a
0.15 molar concentration.
So far we have added 0.75x10^-3
moles.
This strong base will react
with the acid.
It will pull off a hydrogen
ion, or a proton,
from the weak acid and convert
it to its conjugate base.
Now we need to figure out how
much we have left after this
reaction.
We had 2.5x10^-3 moles of the
weak acid.
We have now converted over
0.75x10^-3 moles.
We have 1.75x10^-3 moles of the
acid left.
And now we formed 0.75x10^-3
moles of the conjugate,
so 0.75x10^-3 moles have been
converted from acid to the
conjugate base.
Now we need to know the
molarities of those amounts,
so we take the weak acid,
the number of moles divided by
the total volume now,
which is 25 plus the 5 we just
added, or 30 milliliters.
And we have a concentration.
And then we do the same with a
weak base, number of moles that
we have divided by the new
volume gives you the molarity.
Right at the end of class you
said, okay, the next thing you
can do, there are two different
options.
One option, which we talked
about, was set up this little
equilibrium table.
And the important point to
remember, and when you set this
up, is that you have the weak
acid and its conjugate over
here.
And the other problem is when
you just have a weak acid and
water problem,
you just have the weak acid,
or if you have a weak base in
water problem,
you just start with a weak
base.
Here, this is really like a
buffer problem.
You have both the acid and its
conjugate to some amount,
so you need to put things on
both sides.
We had come up with the pH of
3.38.
And you have to set up using
Ka, check your assumptions and
calculate pH.
There is another way that you
can do this particular problem,
and that is option two.
The first part is the same.
You have to do all the
calculations with a number of
moles and calculate molarity.
The second part is different.
Instead of setting up that
equilibrium table,
you can use the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
In this case,
you need to know pKa.
And you know Ka.
You take the minus log of Ka to
get pKa.
And then you can fill in your
concentration of the weak acid
and the concentration of the
conjugate base that is formed
after the addition of 5 mLs.
And then you can calculate.
And you should definitely get
the same pH out of this 3.38.
Now, this equation,
the Henderson-Hasselbalch
equation, only works with the
assumption that x is small,
so that 5% rule that we talked
about.
And that is because in the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation,
if you were to remember back,
we are making an assumption.
We are assuming that the
initial concentrations that we
have are the same as the
concentrations we have at
equilibrium, which is basically
saying x is small.
You can only use it if x is,
in fact, small.
The way that you would check,
in this case,
is you have to back calculate.
You know your pH answer,
and then you have to calculate
then what the hydronium ion
concentration was,
which is easy because pH just
equals minus log of hydronium
ion concentration.
And so you can get this answer
out.
Then you take this and divide
by either of these two.
You want to use really the
smaller one or both of them and
see, is x small?
And, in this case,
both of those are less than 5%.
4.2x10^-4 is less than 5% of
this number and of this number,
so that assumption is okay.
If it was not okay,
you would have to have used
option one and used the
quadratic equation.
If x is not small,
the only way you can do it is
option one with quadratic.
But most of the time,
x is small because we are
talking about weak acids and
bases.
And a lot of people find the
Henderson-Hasselbalch a faster
way to get the answer.
And as you are doing these
problem sets,
you realize these problems take
a while to do.
And on a 50 minute exam,
part of the process in thinking
about how to do these problems
should be how can I do the
problem the fastest to get it
done?
And a lot of people find this
to be a little bit of a faster
way to do it.
Henderson-Hasselbalch only
works for buffers,
so it only works under
conditions where you are
starting with an acid and its
conjugate base or a base and its
conjugate acid.
Only in the buffer region will
Henderson-Hasselbalch apply,
but when it does apply,
you should think about using
it.
All right.
Let's put our other pH up here.
After we have added 5 mLs,
then we have a pH of 3.38.
Okay.
Now we have reached a special
point called the half
equivalence point.
This is right in the middle of
this buffering region.
Again, the buffering region is
the part of the curve that is
flat, where you are adding your
strong base but it is not
changing the pH very much,
because the solution is being
buffered.
The pH is staying the same,
so it is the flat part of the
curve.
And right in the middle of the
flat part, you find the half
equivalence point.
That is when you have added,
in this case,
half the amount of the strong
base that you need to reach the
equivalence point.
At the equivalence point,
the number of moles of strong
base are equal to the number of
moles of weak acid you had to
begin with.
At the half equivalence point,
you have converted half over to
the conjugate base.
You have the half of the acid
you started with,
and half of it is being
converted.
This is in the buffering
region, and so you can use the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
And you see that if you plugged
in values into here and you
would have equal amounts of
these two, you have converted
half the amounts,
you half this and half that,
and you solved the log,
you would find this term drops
out.
And so pH just equals pKa.
If you know the pKa,
and usually the Ka is given so
you can easily calculate the
pKa, then that is the pH.
The pKa is 3.75,
so that is then also the pH at
the half equivalence point.
Here would be 3.75 at the half
equivalence point.
Now, when I was mentioning that
on an exam you are going to look
for fast ways to solve the
problem, if you are asked about
the pH at a half equivalence
point, you can write pH equals
pKa equals 3.75.
That is it.
It might be a number of points
question, but that is all you
are looking for and you give the
answer.
This is a fast problem.
Make sure that you remember
this trick.
You can work it out the long
way and figure out the same
answer, but this is a perfectly
acceptable answer to say that pH
equals pKa equals 3.75.
That is a shortcut for doing
these problems.
Then we get to the equivalence
point.
I mean, sometimes you might
have here, this has point D also
in the curve,
but we will skip that.
You would do that problem the
same way you did the problem on
the other side of the half
equivalence point,
so we can skip over that and
move right to the equivalence
point.
Again, the equivalence point,
also called the stoichiometric
point, is when you have added
the amount of strong base,
the moles of strong base,
that are equal to the moles of
the weak acid you had to begin
with.
You have converted all of your
weak acid to its conjugate.
In terms of the pH,
the pH is going to depend on
the salt that is formed as a
result of this addition.
In the case when you are
titrating a weak acid with a
strong base, you are going to
get a pH greater than 7 because
all of your weak acid will be
converted to the conjugate base.
All you are going to have
around is conjugate base,
and base is basic,
so you are going to be greater
than 7.
In this case,
you will get the conjugate base
in the form of a salt and water.
The Na plus doesn't do
anything for you.
It has no effect on pH.
All Group 1 and Group 2 have no
effect on pH,
but we have a conjugate base,
so we are going to have a pH
greater than 7 at the
equivalence point.
And this is a good way to
quickly check your math.
If you know what kind of
problem it is and you don't get
a pH that is greater than 7 for
this type of problem,
you know you have made some
kind of math mistake somewhere
along.
And you can go back and try to
find that.
All right.
How do you do the problems?
You want to find the pH then at
the equivalence point.
The exact pH.
You know it is greater than 7,
but what is it exactly?
The first thing you need to do
is find the total volume,
and you need to know the volume
of NaOH that you added to the
solution to get to the
equivalence point.
You know how many moles of acid
you had to begin with.
2.5x10^-3.
That is how many moles,
then, of conjugate base you
formed.
And that must be how many moles
of OH you needed to add to get
the equivalence point.
You need this number of moles.
This was your concentration.
And so that is how many liters
needed to be added to get the
equivalence point.
And in terms of your total
volume, then,
you had 25 milliliters to begin
with.
You are adding 16.7 of the
base.
Now you are at 41.7 milliliters
of volume.
All right.
Just to show this again in
cartoon form.
The point to remember,
at this equivalence point,
is that this is all you have.
You just have that conjugate
base.
If you had four molecules of
weak acid to begin with,
and you added four molecules of
NaOH, then each molecule of NaOH
or of OH will pluck one of these
hydrogen ions off and will leave
you, then, just with a conjugate
base.
You are going to have equal
moles here to what you had here,
so you have these equal moles.
In terms then of the molarity
of this, you have to have the
same number of moles now of the
weak base as what you had of the
weak acid to start with.
You have converted all of it to
the weak base.
You have that many moles,
and you calculated the total
volume, so you know your new
molarity.
This is just a weak base in
water problem.
And we talked already about how
to do this.
We can set up this table here.
Now all we have is the weak
base.
We don't have any of this left.
It has all been converted,
so all we have is this.
We have 0.0600 molar minus x,
x and x.
Now, again, you cannot use the
Henderson-Hasselbalch here.
It is not a buffer problem.
We have to solve it using Kb,
because it is a base in water.
We cannot use Ka.
We have to use Kb for a base in
water.
Kb is the base ionization
constant.
If I was given a Ka,
how would I find the Kb for the
conjugate?
What would I use?
Kw, right.
That is an easy conversion,
using Kw to calculate Kb.
And then that would be equal to
x squared over 0.06 minus x.
We can simplify that if x is
small, double check that that is
okay, and if we do that,
we find that the OH
concentration is 1.83x10^-6
molar.
Then we can calculate a pOH,
and from that we can calculate
the pH.
It would be 14 minus this,
and the pH is 8.226.
That is greater than seven,
so that makes sense.
We can draw that up here.
We have 8.26 at the equivalence
point.
And that is greater than 7,
which is what we expect.
It should be basic.
Now, a lot of people forget,
because they are going quickly,
to convert from pOH to pH.
And that should be a way to
double-check.
If you find out that you are
the equivalence point and the pH
is less than seven,
you realize that something is
wrong.
And hopefully you will remember
to convert, then,
to pH.
Greater than seven.
All right.
Beyond the equivalence point,
so the last kind of point that
you may have in a curve up here.
Beyond the equivalence point,
you still have your conjugate
base hanging out and you still
have all that you had here,
but that was not making the
solution really very basic.
There wasn't much.
It was like 10^-6 molar.
There was not much of it.
And so the pH is really going
to be determined only by the
amount of excess OH that is
added to the solution.
Now you can forget all about
your weak acids and weak bases
at this pint and just look at
this problem as a strong base
problem.
You are swamping the system
with your excess strong base.
This kind of problem at the
end, past the equivalence point,
is going to be a strong acid,
strong base type problem.
In this case,
a strong base problem.
We know how to do this already.
We talked about this before.
If you are 5 mLs beyond,
and you say 5 mLs times the
concentration,
so you have 7.5x10^-4 moles of
excess base.
The only trick to this problem
is remembering the entire volume
that you have in there.
You know how many moles you
have, and it is 5 mLs past,
you had 25 mLs to begin with,
you added 16.7 to get to the
equivalence point,
add those together and you can
get the concentration.
Now, remember the concentration
we had at the equivalence point
of OH was like 10^-6.
That is still around,
but if you add something of
10^-6 to this number it is not
significantly going to change it
at all.
You can ignore that and only
consider the concentration of
the OH that is due to that
excess strong base added and
calculate the pOH,
and then from that the pH.
Our final point on the curve
then, somewhere up here,
12.21.
And this is 5 mLs beyond the
equivalence point.
There we have a titration
curve, where we have calculated
various points along the way.
The point to remember in doing
these problems is that you just
need to break down each part of
the curve and define it as a
different type of problem.
Here we started out and we did
a weak acid problem.
Then we were in the buffering
region and we did a buffer
problem.
We had this special category of
buffer when we were at the half
equivalence point.
And then we moved up here.
All the weak acid was converted
to weak base at this point,
so it is just a weak base
problem.
And then beyond the equivalence
point it is a strong base
problem.
The titration curve,
this is why it takes a long
time to do these,
because it is really many
problems all wrapped up into one
problem.
And the other thing to
remember, especially if you are
given different subsections,
is you are not always going to
be working through it
systematically.
You may be asked to start here
or start down here.
And so you always have to ask
yourself what kind of problem is
this?
And I tell people who are
grading the exam that if you
write on the top of the problem,
this is really a buffer problem
or this is a weak base problem
at the equivalence point,
if you write something down
that tells me that you know what
type of problem it is,
that is worth some points right
there, even if you get lost in
the math.
If you think about these in a
way that will help you do them,
it also might give you a little
partial credit on the test.
All right.
Again, there are just these
types of problems.
And it is a matter of picking
and choosing and putting them
all together.
There are not a huge number of
types of problems,
but it is hard sometimes for
people to figure out where they
are, and which one of these
things to apply.
All right.
That moves into today's
handout.
I am going to start today's
handout finishing acid-base.
And I did this for the first
time last year,
this kind of little cheat sheet
on how to solve these problems.
And I will write this stuff on
the board.
And as maybe some of you
remember, I mentioned that last
year we had the best performance
on acid-base that I think we
have seen in 5.111 for a really
long time.
People did really,
really well on this.
And so I would like to continue
that trend of having fantastic
acid-base titration answers,
where there are little smiley
faces drawn on the exams where
everything is really perfect.
Let's see if we can keep this
going.
All right.
Let's work on our cheat sheet
and how you go about solving all
the different kinds of problems.
First we will just quickly
review this type,
the weak acid being titrated
with a strong base.
Let's consider now,
we will work backwards through
this, when we are beyond the
equivalence point.
And I guess I should say,
this is weak acid,
strong base.
Okay.
Beyond the equivalence point,
then, is a strong base problem,
as we just did.
It is really due to the excess
strong base that we had.
We would solve this problem
saying, okay,
the extra strong base,
and that is the number of
moles, over the total volume.
And that is going to give you
the concentration of hydroxide
ion.
And then you can find pOH and
then pH.
That is how you would do that
category of problem here.
Let's move, then,
to volume equals the volume at
the equivalence point.
And this is a salt problem that
gets broken down into a weak
base problem,
because now we have converted
all our weak acid into its
conjugate base.
This is an A minus plus
H2O going to HA plus OH minus
type problem.
And we would use Kb,
because we are talking about a
base in water,
to find the concentration of
hydroxide ions.
Then you would calculate pOH
and then pH.
And you should know how to
write an equation out for all
the types of problems you are
doing.
It will help you figure out
what you are doing in the
problem.
When your volume equals the
volume at the half equivalence
point, pH equals pKa.
And that is really it.
You might have to find pKa from
Ka, but that is pretty
straightforward.
Now, when you are in the
buffering region,
again, the buffering region is
where the pH titration curve is
in the flat region.
This is a buffer problem.
And here mostly you want to try
to use the Henderson-Hasselbalch
equation, pH equals pKa minus
the log of HA divided by A minus
of your weak acid and
the conjugate base.
And you can use this if the
5% rule applies,
but that usually does,
so that is probably going to be
your first route to do these
calculations.
Again, you have to find the
concentrations of these.
You have to remember that the
amount of strong base you are
adding is converting some of the
weak acid to the conjugate.
You need to find out how much
gets converted,
find these concentrations and
then plug it into this equation.
This equation only works for a
buffer problem.
And I also just want to say
that every once in a while,
people decide instead of pKa,
let's rewrite this equation for
a pKb instead.
Don't do that.
That is my little tip.
It has been tried,
and it has never actually
succeeded in yielding the
correct answer.
If someone wants to say,
on this test,
I will come up with this new
equation using pKb and I will
prove that we can get it,
you can do that if you want,
but I think it is best to stick
with this equation just from
previous experience.
Okay.
Then, lastly,
volume equals zero,
so this is a weak acid problem.
And a weak acid problem,
you have your acid in water
going to hydronium ion
concentrations and your
conjugate base.
You are going to use Ka,
the acid equilibrium constant,
to find hydronium ion
concentration.
And then from that you can
calculate pH.
Those are the different ways
that that breaks down.
Now let's do the same thing for
a weak base, strong acid.
And I will move that onto the
next.
To start with,
start at the top of the chart.
Here, in the beginning,
when volume equals zero,
all you have is your weak base.
And then, as you add acid,
the pH is going to drop.
In the beginning,
when volume equals zero,
this is a weak base problem.
And so you can draw that as
your base in water going to the
conjugate acid and hydroxide ion
concentration.
Now you are going to use Kb,
the base ionization equilibrium
constant, to find the
concentration of OH minus.
Then you can calculate pOH,
and from that,
calculate pH.
Next, we will consider the
buffering region when the volume
is in between zero and the
volume at the equivalence point.
And so this is a buffer
problem.
Again, I recommend using
Henderson-Hasselbalch as written
with pKa.
And so here you need to know
the concentration of the
conjugate acid over the
concentration of the weak base
that you had.
And so you can use this if the
5% rule applies.
And you can check that by
calculating.
This will also work.
Now, remember.
you are starting.
then.
with your weak base.
You have converted some of it
to the conjugate acid.
depending on how much strong
acid you have added.
Before you can plug in numbers
here, you have to subtract how
many moles of the strong acid
were added, so that means,
how many moles of the weak base
do you have left,
how many moles of the conjugate
acid have been formed.
Again, we are in this region.
If you had, say,
four molecules to begin with,
and you added one molecule of
the strong acid,
then you would be left with
three and you would have one
converted.
These problems all involve
subtractions before you can plug
in your numbers to the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
Then we have the special
category of buffer where your
volume equals the volume at the
half equivalence point.
Again, you can just solve this.
pH equals pKa.
If you are given a Kb,
you will have to convert to a
Ka to find your pKa,
but this will still work.
Maybe I will write on this next
board.
Then your volume at the
equivalence point.
And this is,
again, a salt problem.
But the salt problem breaks
down to a weak acid problem
because when you have a strong
acid, its conjugate is neutral.
And if you have a weak base,
its conjugate is also a weak
acid.
The salt that is formed in this
problem is going to be acidic.
We can write that down.
We have our conjugate acid that
has formed as a result of the
titration in water forming the
conjugate base and hydronium ion
concentrations.
Now we can use Ka to find
hydronium ion concentration,
and then we can calculate pH.
Again, at the equivalence
point, you converted all of the
weak base you had down to weak
acid.
You have added enough acid that
it has protonated all of the
weak base you have and now all
you have left is acid,
so it is really just an acid in
water problem.
And then, finally,
if you are beyond the
equivalence point,
now you are just pouring excess
acid in.
And so this is a strong acid
problem.
You still will have a little
acid solution left from the
titration, but that is going to
be overwhelmed by the amount of
strong acid.
You can solve that by just
saying how many extra moles of
strong acid over the total
volume.
And that is going to give you
hydronium ion concentration and
then you can calculate pH.
At this point it is just a very
simple calculation.
The only tricky part is to
figure out the total volume,
to get that number right.
That is the cheat sheet which
should help lead you through the
rest of the problem set and also
problems for the exam.
Let's do a little bit,
we have just a little bit that
I want to do today on
oxidation-reduction reactions.
And so this is the next unit
that we are moving into.
And today we are just going to
talk in the last 15 minutes
about some simple rules for
doing oxidation-reduction.
We are also moving away from
the acid-base,
but you will find there are a
lot of parallels between these
units.
We are still going to be
talking about equilibrium
constants.
We are still going to be
talking about delta G as we go
along.
This is another application of
thermodynamics and chemical
equilibrium.
There are some rules to start
with.
Most of them are actually
pretty simple.
And you need to know what these
rules are for assigning
oxidation numbers.
Here are the rules.
If you have a free element,
the oxidation number is going
to be zero.
If you have ions then your
oxidation number,
here is lithium plus one.
You have an oxidation number of
plus one, so the oxidation
number is equal to the charge on
the atom.
And we find that Group 1 are
always going to have plus one,
Group 2 metals on the periodic
table are always going to be
plus two, and aluminum is always
going to be plus three.
Those are the ones that will
help guide you through doing
these problems.
Oxygen is a little bit more
tricky, but it almost always
minus two.
The only exception is in
peroxides, where you have a
minus one state.
This will also help you in
solving a lot of these problems,
but you are actually going to
have a couple of examples where
oxygen is a bit different.
Hydrogen also is usually plus
one, but there are exceptions.
And you will actually see a
number of exceptions in this
unit.
You should know that in these
particular cases it will be
minus one.
Here we have Group 1 and Group
2 metals which will always be
plus.
And so in this case,
hydrogen is minus one.
Fluorine is always minus one.
Other halogens are usually
minus one, but there are some
exceptions.
When you combine it with oxygen
you have an exception to that.
And so then you could have a
different oxidation state when
it is combined in these
oxoacids.
And so then you would have a
positive oxidation state or
oxidation number.
All right.
Things need to add up.
In neutral molecules the sum of
all the oxidation numbers needs
to be equal to zero.
If you have a polyatomic anion,
the sum of the oxidation
numbers needs to add up to the
net charge on that particular
ion.
You need to be able to sum to
get the overall charge of the
molecule.
All right.
Let's look at an example,
NH four plus.
What would the oxidation number
of hydrogen be in this case?
It will be plus one here.
What about nitrogen?
And so the sum needs to add up.
And so if you have four plus
1s, minus 3, gives you plus 1.
There is one
example.
All right.
Another rule is that they don't
always have to be integers.
Most of the time they are,
but the oxidation number of
oxygen in O two minus one
would be what?
Minus a half for each
individual oxygen atom in there.
That is kind of one of the only
exceptions to this.
You won't see this very often.
All right.
Let's look at a couple more
examples to get you used to
doing these problems.
And I will just erase this part
right here.
Okay.
Let's look at lithium two oxide.
What is oxygen going to be in
this compound?
It will be minus two,
and lithium will be plus one.
Lithium is always going to be
plus one.
And so if we have plus 2 minus
2 that gives us 0,
which is the overall charge.
There was no charge.
That was a neutral molecule,
so that worked out.
Let's look at PCl five.
What is chloride going to be in
this case?
Minus one.
We have 5 times minus 1.
What does that give us for
phosphorus?
Plus 5.
You will actually find in this
unit on oxidation-reduction,
we are going to go into
balancing oxidation-reduction
equations, too,
and oxidation numbers,
it is counting.
This unit, lots of counting.
It may be a little break.
I think people find the
acid-base titrations a little
bit more, they have to think
more.
Here, you count,
so that might be a little nice
relief coming up.
Okay.
HNO three,
what would be oxygen?
Minus two, and we have three of
those.
What is hydrogen going to be
here?
Plus one.
What does that leave us for
nitrogen?
Plus five, right,
to get our overall sum equal to
zero.
And one last one.
N two O.
What is oxygen here?
Minus two.
What does that mean nitrogen
has to be?
Plus one.
Two plus one to give us zero.
See, nitrogen can have lots of
different numbers.
And a number of atoms can.
That is why knowing some things
in the rules about oxygen,
chloride and other things will
help you figure out then what
that other molecule has to be.
All right.
Here are the whole set of
rules.
Okay.
Oops, going in the wrong
direction.
All right.
Let's look at a few
definitions.
Oxidation, most of these should
be familiar to people.
Oxidation means that you are
losing an electron.
Reduction means that you are
gaining an electron.
And then we have an oxidizing
agent, and an oxidizing agent is
something that accepts electrons
and gets reduced itself.
And a reducing agent is
something that is going to
donate the electrons,
give electrons away,
so it itself becomes oxidized.
And these two terms often
confuse people because an
oxidizing agent goes and
oxidizes other things,
but it itself is reduced,
so it is an agent of oxidation.
It is running around trying to
oxidize other things.
That is the part to remember.
Sometimes people get these
parts backwards.
These are really a lot of the
definitions you need to know.
There are not so many
definitions in this particular
unit.
One other term that you need to
be familiar with in here is
these disproportionation
reactions.
And so, like we saw with
acid-base where we could have
something that could serve as an
acid and a base is amphoteric.
We also find that you can have
an element that can be both
oxidized and reduced in a
particular reaction.
We saw that with acid-base we
had water plus water going to
hydronium ion and hydroxide ion,
where one molecule of water was
acting as an acid and the other
was acting as a base.
A similar kind of idea here,
but in this case we are having
one thing be oxidized and
reduced.
Let's take a quick look at
that.
We can break this down to two
different equations.
And sodium is a spectator ion.
Poor sodium really doesn't get
to do much of anything in both
this unit and the last unit.
And we are only focusing on
these species here.
You are going to have one ClO
minus going to ClO
three minus and
another one going to Cl
minus.
What is happening here?
Let's take a look at what is
happening.
Let's look at the oxidation
numbers.
Oxygen here will be minus two.
What does that leave for this
chloride?
If we write that out,
it all has to be equal to one.
That would be plus one.
And let's consider what is
going on over here.
Again, this minus two,
three of them here.
And it all needs to be equal to
minus one over here.
What does that leave for this?
We have plus five.
We are going from plus one here
to plus five.
And so this particular guy is
being oxidized.
It is losing electrons here.
Now let's look down here.
We already did this one.
It is the same.
We are at plus one.
And here we are going to minus
one.
We have this particular guy
going from plus one to minus
one, so it is being reduced.
You have the same chloride in
both cases, but in one reaction
it is being oxidized and in the
other it is being reduced.
That is an example of a
disproportionation reaction and
also another example of how you
look at what the oxidation
numbers are.
All right.
Let's see if we can actually
get through some of this,
these balancing reactions.
How many people have seen
balancing oxidation-reduction
reactions before?
A lot of people.
Again, it is counting.
I think we can go through this
very fast.
You have to consider whether an
acid solution or basic solution
at least some of the time.
Let's do acid solution first.
You can take this and write
your unbalanced equations out
for this.
Break it down into two halves
and figure out what is
happening.
Again, here we have minus 2
times 7.
And it all has to be minus two.
This oxidation would be what?
6 times 2.
We are plus 6 to plus 3 over
here.
Plus 6 to plus 3,
and so we have a reduction.
We are going down in number
here.
And so this one is the
reduction, and that is good
because over here we have plus
two to plus three,
so we have our oxidation in the
other part.
You are always going to have
oxidation-reduction.
You will always have something
being oxidized and something
else being reduced.
Now we have to balance this.
And so the first thing you are
going to do, you are going to
look and insert coefficients to
balance the elements,
except for oxygen and hydrogen,
on both sides.
Do we need to do something up
here?
If so, what?
Multiply by two.
What about down here?
Nothing.
Now we are going to add water
to balance oxygen.
Again, we only need to worry
about one side.
There are seven oxygens here,
so we have to add seven waters
on the other side.
We have our seven waters here.
Now we want to balance
hydrogens.
And you can add H plus.
The book uses hydronium ion,
which makes it much harder,
so I suggest you don't do that
and just add H plus.
If you just add H plus,
how much do you need to add?
You need to add 14 to the other
side.
Again, nothing down here.
And so now you need to balance
charge by adding electrons.
In this case it is going to be
plus six because we have 14
minus two on this side and we
have this six on the other side.
And then over here,
what do we have to add?
We just have to add one.
Now we take this,
and we need to multiply the
reactions so the number of
electrons are equal.
We would multiply by six here.
And now our electrons are
equal.
The electrons have to cancel
out.
If they don't you have done
something wrong.
Now we add and make the
appropriate cancellations.
Here is the whole equation.
And we should be able to cancel
out electrons.
If we don't we did something
wrong.
And can we cancel anything else
out?
Not really.
You want to double-check that
it is balanced.
14 Hs here.
Two chromiums.
The seven oxygens and the six
irons, that is the same on the
other side, the same charge on
both sides.
And then, finally,
if it is in basic solution,
all we are going to do,
the same steps,
is adjust the pH by adding OH.
If we had 14 plus,
we would add 14 OHs and then
come along and you would add
those up.
And then you can cancel again.
And so now, instead of having H
plus,
we have OH.
And so in acidic solution you
would have H plus,
and in basic solution you have
OH.
That is balancing.
It is pretty simple.
You just have to make sure that
everything adds up.